he's one of the stars of Wofford Wofford
knocked off Seton Hall shouldn't be a
surprise they were favored going into
that game and Kentucky is waiting for
Wofford they're a senior guard fletcher
mcgee joins us fletcher good morning how
do you feel
good morning good this morning you know
just had a lot of you know support and
hi from our fans and people here last
night but you know we're walking in on
kentucky now and johnny ready for that
game i'm curious if somebody has not
seen you play and you were gonna
describe your style how would you do it
I would say just kind of unconventional
um I mean obviously I'm a you know
three-point shooter but I feel like I
you know get it done just in a way that
you know a lot of people you know
haven't seen or are used to seeing with
you know off-balance shots and you know
different looking type of angles and
stuff like that um so I would say Kahn
that's one of the main things that you
know people would notice st. Nicholas
who taught you how to shoot well Bo
busting my coach that I had an in
between 8th and 9th grade kind of helped
me you know real real on my form
um and get my shot mechanics right but
I've always you know played basketball
just growing up and just try to you know
get a feel for the rim stuff I feel like
you know that time period kind of
changed my shot what's that feeling like
do you have the green light to shoot
whenever you want to what point did you
get the green light Fletcher not really
but you know our teammates do a great
job in screening for me and entrusting
me with a lot of the shots I shoot coach
young you know our coach no no I don't
care about that I just want to know what
is it like to go down the floor and know
you can shoot whenever you want to and
not get Yona I feel like it helps your
your shooting percentage just because
you know your shooting you know without
a conscious and not really thinking too
much about you know is it's a good shot
it's a bad shot what is your range
I would say probably from like 28 to 30
feet or so something like that do you
think you could take Steph Curry right
now on a three-point shooting contest
I'm not gonna say but okay I have to you
know say I believe in myself you know we
would line it up and you know shoot it
all together I'd have to you know
believe myself and think out what okay
if we held it at the Wofford gym you're
taking him down right oh oh yeah I think
so I think I'm you started in the best
player you played against um probably I
played you know with Ben Simmons in a
you a lot you know gets him in practices
so I think he's probably with the
success he's had I think he's probably
the best player that I've lined it up
again in Zion Williamson from the same
town as Wofford yes he uh he's he's in
Spartanburg with the high school about
five or ten minutes from Wofford did
Wofford recruit Zion Williamson oh yeah
we recruited him hard he came on a visit
my sophomore year June I think my
sophomore year and we you know we
welcome to them and tried to you know
pitch our case to him you know being so
close and stuff and you know with a tee
know we were gonna have well you know he
uh he went on to to Duke and to the
biggest rule what if he said look I'll
come there but you know Fletcher's got
to stop shooting so much yeah they could
be worse than that yeah that'd be a good
trade-off you know we get we definitely
have some more drives and dunks and
highlights and stuff with within on us
auntie can you dunk yeah it's like I
could dunk I'll show it off to Boston
games wait did I just insult you
Fletcher when I asked if you could okay
you declared for the NBA Draft last year
but you didn't hire any
what did you find out that made you come
back to Wofford um I think I found out
just you know I need to work on mods you
know passing in my defense I'm making
reads off of the screens you know two
people come to me to find the right guy
I'm just trying to you know get my my
body arm more ready I think no coming
back has definitely helped me focus more
on you know the defensive end and you
know having to guard good players and
obviously in the next level you got the
guard a great player every night so I
feel like just a mindset of working on
my piece tense and focusing on that more
as as healthy this year any doubts about
playing in the NBA um no I mean I think
it's always been you know a dream of
mine um and so you know I'm always gonna
you know believe in myself and in the
work that I put in I mean I think that I
can still get there after you beat
Kentucky who do you face after that I
honestly have no idea what the bracket
looks like
um you know Kentucky's a great team and
we just started looking at their stuff
today so well you're not afraid of
considerating you're not afraid of kids
no I know we're not afraid of them we
know they got some great talent some
great players but you know we're gonna
give them our best shot and you know
we're gonna come into the game confident
yeah but Seton Hall beat Kentucky
earlier this year so you beat Seton Hall
therefore you guys should be Kentucky
hey it's been fun I have to admit I
think it was either the Georgia Tech or
North Carolina game that I sort of you
know got on your radar to watch your
games and you guys are wrong you're not
a one-man team you got a great coach and
that's a great team so congrats so far
and good luck against Kentucky coming up
tomorrow
all right great thank you thanks ml
that's fletcher mcgee pride of Wofford
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
you
[Music]